Pues ya son más de 15 documentos
confidenciales que han encontrado en las
oficinas privadas y en las casas
privadas de Joe biden en este caso en
una biblioteca privada del expresidente
hay que mencionar sin embargo que la
casa de el presidente biden en Delaware
tiene el salvoconducto es decir está
autorizada por el gobierno
estadounidense para tratar información
confidencial incluso para recibir y
hacer llamadas de forma confidencial es
una segunda Casa Blanca Por así decirlo
sin embargo estos documentos fueron
encontrados en áreas donde no se
prohibía este manejo de información
confidencial estos cinco documentos
fueron hallados el jueves por la noche
cuando un consejero de la Casa Blanca
viajó hasta Delaware y recibió estos
documentos que habían sido encontrados
en la librería de el presidente Joe
biden fueron entregados muy rápidamente
después de esta entrega de estos
documentos confidenciales al
departamento de para que adelante esta
investigación que pues lleva a cabo y
sigue en este momento el departamento de
justicia en su rumbo de esta
investigación precisamente pero pues
obviamente quedan muchas preguntas sobre
Por qué se siguen conociendo documentos
confidenciales si si yo bailen en este
periodo cuando fue ex vicepresidente
pues esto pasó hace ya varios años y
apenas ahora se viene a conocer esta
información y como usted ya lo
mencionaba hay una investigación en
curso para entender Por qué biden tenía
estos documentos clasificados con este
nuevo hallazgo en que queda el caso
pues este caso queda en el ojo público
sobre todo y va a haber mucho más
escrutinio Este va a ser definitivamente
el tema de las próximas semanas acá en
Washington porque recordemos que hace
apenas semanas se había designado un
consejero especial se había hecho todo
un enfoque mediático también a los a los
documentos confidenciales que fueron
encontrados en mara lago de el
expresidente Donald Trump y ahora
entonces lo que parece ser es una
tendencia Porque también se conocían
cuestionamientos de Que Barack Obama se
había llevado información confidencial
de la Casa Blanca conocimos el caso del
expresidente Donald Trump y ahora los
casos repetidos de el presidente Joe
biden de haberse llevado información
confidencial a su oficina en Washington
y a su casa privada en Delaware Así que
se viene mucho más escrutinio y se viene
obviamente pues atado a eso un peso
reputacional y un efecto que esto va a
tener en la popularidad en la aceptación
el gobierno de Joe biden de cara
obviamente a esta ambición que tiene él
en los próximos dos años de reelegirse
para el 2024